Bart is an early experiment an
experiment experiment early experiment
yes Xiao is in charge of Google's
new experiment an AI chatbot called Bard
and after a few days of testing it out
myself I can understand why she's
stressing that experiment point for
those just tuning into the AI Wars Bard
is Google's answer to open ai's chat GPT
at its step sibling Microsoft's Bing
chat bot you can type in queries and it
spits out human-like answers
be amazing Until you realize some of the
answers are just wrong
is Bard a search engine Bard is really a
compliment to search we think of it as a
creative collaborator that people can
use to further their ideas and to feel
their imagination okay fine Bard is not
a search engine but you inevitably ask
it search like questions like who are
the main characters in Seinfeld and what
do they do
the answers come in fast often faster
than chat GPT or Bing but some are just
wrong most would agree George's main
profession was not a struggling writer
he was definitely not a struggling
comedian Jerry definitely didn't work at
pendant publishing why did Bard so
confidently say the wrong jobs for these
Seinfeld characters at the heart of Bard
is a large language model large language
models are trained on publicly available
information and then they're just sort
of statistically predicting what you
know next word to to add to the sentence
and as a result sometimes it makes these
mistakes it's hallucinating that a
string of words hopefully you click
thumbs down on that and said this is not
exactly correct and that's the way that
we are able to really improve Bart Bart
is not alone in factual errors I've seen
Lots in bing and Chachi PT though the
two of them wouldn't dare mess up
Seinfeld trivia
the bigger issue I have with Bard is
that it often doesn't show its sources
Bard is trained on lots of a publicly
known information on the internet and on
the internet there's lots of information
about things like Seinfeld and common
topics we do Astro a sources link when
there is a direct citation that the
content is coming from but a lot of the
output itself is really being generated
by the model one of the big questions
what types of data were these systems
trained on what websites news sources
did it learn from most of them almost
all of them are trained on you know
publicly available information and
further we augment it with our
understanding of high value high quality
Source information to make Bard more
accurate is Gmail data included in that
Gmail data is not included we've talked
a little bit about truth and things that
are not true why put it out there at all
the technology is ready people are
excited people want to engage and
discuss us and learn what this
technology does at the same time you
know a lot of the work is not just in
the llm itself but in all the safeguards
and safety protections and that we've
put in place to get to the point where
we feel comfortable enough to put an
experiment to the world Bard does have a
a Google it button so you can get taken
directly to Google results if you want
more information and it does say
responses may be inaccurate while using
Bard I've noticed it is cautious and
limited compared to chat GPT and Bing it
can often remind you that it's a large
language model and can't answer whatever
you've just asked it feels like you're
holding Bard on a very tight leash
restricting it from doing things and
different responses why you're calling
it a leash I actually think of it as
safeguards and guardrails like this is a
powerful technology we want to make sure
that we understand you know how to bring
it in a responsible way to to people
openai doesn't have a search business
Microsoft has a very small search
business and they don't have a lot to
lose by putting out a chat bot that
maybe people use to to search is that
part of the calculation in Google's
limiting of this tool what we do is take
Cutting Edge technology and bring it to
users hands and make their lives helpful
we need to do that in a safe and
responsible way with a new technology
like this and that's how we're doing it
and does it disappoint the team or was
it expected that people are sort of
saying Bart is boring I actually think
we feel really good that Bard is being
safe and actually people are finding
those guard rails and they're bumping up
against those things when people are
testing things that are sort of you know
trying to you know push the boundaries
of course experiments don't always work
like when I asked it for my own bio
Stern is a graduate of Union College
true and holds a master's degree in
journalism from Columbia University not
true but thank you Bard but in this case
Google seems committed to a future where
we talk to our computers in more natural
ways when I was growing up watching Star
Trek or you know Marvel movies where
Tony Stark is talking to his Ai and his
helmet like I think that is a Sci-Fi
dream that is like something that humans
are very fascinated with right that
having an AI that can speak to you
naturally or you know converse with you
that said you know people take can take
llms and tune them towards personas or
characters you know that's not what
we're doing with Bard in the near term
she assures me that the experiment will
get better and bolder
my lastest part of note is that it
learns more about Seinfeld It's a
Wonderful show we'll get on that right
away